Mm.
So I've been asked choosing an
amendment,
uh,
that I think is important and valuable.
And so I think the first amendment,
and it's not only because it's the first
amendment,
it's what it says and it says,
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof or abridging
the freedom of speech or of the press or
the right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances.
And I think from the constitution,
this sets up the rest of the
constitution about what it means to be
an American citizen and the value of our
individual liberties because it sets us
apart as individuals.
We have the right to speech,
we have the right to association,
we have the right to religion,
we can think,
we can act,
we can associate freely.
And as a scholar of international
relations,
when you poll people around the world
and they ask us,
what is it that you think is most
important about the United States that
you think sets the United States apart?
More often than not,
people point to the first amendment.
And to the freedom of speech,
the freedom of assembly,
the freedom of religion.
Um,
as first and foremost what makes the
United States special,
that we privilege individuals as
citizens and our constitution protects
that we need to keep that in mind as
citizens.
And I have to tell you around the world,
people acknowledge that and respect that
about the United States.
You know,
I really have a hard time with this.
I so,
so this idea of freedom of assembly and
freedom of speech,
regardless of the nature of that speech.
I mean there are exceptions to that
about whether it propagates violence or
potentially promulgates violence.
Um,
and I tend to come down on the liberal
side that people should have freedom of
speech and that as you know,
defender of the,
you know,
the first amendment of the constitution
that then you need to redouble your
efforts to make sure that there's,
if you fear that this is going to lead
to violence,
a conflict that you redouble your
efforts and have police and you make
arrests and you said you've overstepped
your boundaries.
So I tend to be somebody,
let them assemble.
Let them have their freedom of speech
and redouble your efforts and take
measures to ensure that that can happen.